in this episode I talk about giving away
your best work for free hitting the
pavement and we spoke to Darth bill you
ask questions and I answer them this is
the askgaryvee show
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 73 of the askgaryvee
show before we get into the show I think
you guys probably could tell I'm coming
in with a very serious attitude for
episode 73 just came out of intense
meeting got more intense meetings on the
back side and so you should be prepared
for intense Carlow asks I sometimes feel
that giving away some of my best work
for free might mean others perceiving it
as less valuable is this a true risk or
is this for the right hook balances it
all out Karl is a solid question you
know I think at some level there is a
risk about giving away your best work
for free for me that's been the gateway
drug at some level because I think best
work needs to be defined it depends on
what your work is for example I'm blown
away by people who don't realize that
their best advice is exactly what you
should give away for free because if
you're in this selling advice business
you really need to give contextual
advice so I can theoretically talk about
snapchat being important but then when I
meet the tire company we have to
formulate it to work within that context
and so that advice is then gonna be
specific if you're a painter and your
best work is the greatest painting you
ever made and then you gave it away for
free that's not maybe a little bit of a
different game but if you strategically
gave it away like to a very important
museum or to a very important
billionaire that puts it in the prime
spot in their home could that then
become the gateway the problem is with
this question and this debate is that
when you are doing something for free it
needs to be strategic because what
you're looking to do by giving away
something for free is to create leverage
to then do something that is not for
free and so you know d-roc could have
made a video for a bunch of different
characters and maybe you wouldn't have
panned out to have the ROI that he
received by doing a video for free for
me for free and so I think that
oftentimes people look at this as a
blanket statement to me all the good
stuff I give away for free has strategic
purpose I understand why I'm doing it
and that's why it becomes so much easier
to do even though I don't always expect
the outcome
that action and I think that becomes a
big part way too many people do things
for free give away their best work for
free and then expect this windfall
behind it and when that's not delivered
they become disappointed and within that
disappointment they don't follow up and
do it again and make it a replica action
which has more upside that in a three
out of five times where it brings value
you focused on the two out of five and
that kind of squashed you so that's my
answer
Darth bill asks should a new small
business join a local Chamber of
Commerce in order to build a brand in
the community they live in I've never
had much ROI in networking groups you
know Darth Bill the answer is probably
but maybe it's not the group's problem
maybe it's your problem maybe you're not
good at networking right and so you know
I think you need to look yourself in the
mirror
Darth and I'm gonna continue with the
pause because I don't want to leave it
that negative because I like bill even
though I'm in a little bit of a focused
mood there's no reason to be zingy you
know I think you need to really know
yourself that one of the biggest reasons
I do go to a lot of networking thing and
I don't go to Chamber of Commerce though
I did we were part of one brand and
loved it I won't let me forget loved the
concept of the Chamber of Commerce I
mean not you know I think that you
really need to know yourself and if you
don't find yourself as someone who is
strong at networking or has that gear to
go up to people and say hello and you
don't have that bullcrap gear where
you're just going up to everybody and
handing your business card you know then
then maybe it's not for you I mean we
really need to bet on strengths you know
that's a big thesis of mine and so I
would look at yourself versus if you
were not good in that environment then
maybe you shouldn't be putting yourself
in that position here our movie podcast
asks what value do you place on getting
out there and pressing the flesh in
order to expand your fan base here a
movie podcast can I call you HMP I think
I can HMP I you know I have enormous
value in it you go into a confide area
where there's like-minded fans - exactly
what you do and you know listen nothing
replaces a nice little selfie or a hug
or a high-five you know I think you use
the digital world as a gateway drug to
then meet in person - then solidify and
then kick back out into the digital
world
to create amplifications so I'm a huge
fan of pounding the pavement showing up
in real world places it continues to be
a reason I go to things like South by
Southwest and I'm a big fan of it I
don't think you can just do it in the
data world we're still human for now
robot culture coming but not right this
second and so marking in the year that
you live in 2015
hitting the pavement yes hey I'm here
with members of Slovak crowd we just say
that vaynermedia San Francisco and we
have a question for you answer our
question we are acquiring Orchestra that
has existed for about five years and
we're looking to grow we have an
audience of about three to five thousand
at our big concerts in order for us to
continue to grow we need to get more
corporate sponsorships from bigger
companies but they already support an
orchestra like the San Francisco
Symphony so how do we get them to
support us as well first of all thank
you so much for coming to Vayner SF and
and wowing them with your skills you
know look I made a very classic
old-school Gary Vaynerchuk video for way
back when I'll link it up right here
indie rock you know this one is the cold
call video this seems to be a very
simple answer my friends I think that
you guys may be tremendous at singing
but selling might be a very different
thing and so you need to find who can
sell and sing or who can just sell while
you guys sing because the truth is you
just hit the ground right you like
there's a billion places to go and you
just literally go ask all of them I'm
always blown away by people saying oh
we're in big trouble
like people are supporting other things
or there's nowhere to go there's always
somewhere to go get creative like you
you're you know are they in San
Francisco so yeah I mean Jesus Christ
you've got nothing but funded Green
TechCrunch and recoat every day look at
every code company that just raised 50
million dollars and go knock on their
door and say give me 3000 I mean like
you know I mean it's like it's crazy it
you know this question to a Salesman is
like me asking you how do I sing right
like like you would answer you just sing
what the funny part is is I just might
suck at singing right and you might suck
at sales and so I think you need to
figure out who can do that for you
because the answer to your question is
extremely basic literally go to the
phone book what I mean by that is
literally hit up every single business
in San Francisco all of them Rick's
carwash to Google from everybody from
Rick's to Google that's right dear rock
you weren't expecting that were you and
so Google Rick's carwash and every
company in between gets hit up by you
guys and somebody's gonna give you cash
and I'm gonna guess it's gonna be more
than just somebody Apollo poetry asks
when all is said and done how would you
like to be remembered this is a
tremendous question this finally put me
in a decent mood you know look I think I
think that selfishly I would like to be
remembered as the greatest human being
that ever lived the earth you know we're
trying to keep it basic and modest you
know I'd like to I'd like to think that
um I like to think that people
appreciated my effort and and and and
whatever the way they define that right
like the hustle culture that I've
created that you know is clearly I'm so
humbled by the notion that it's inspired
people to work harder and create things
but like the effort on like on an
individual level and like all the
behind-the-scenes stuff like look I
often say I live my life on a daily
basis with the complete intent to have
everybody that I interact with show up
to my funeral and I think the only way
you can do that is to be remembered as
such a good person that you created
guilt that people have to go out of
their way on their busy days to show up
to your funeral even though you only met
twice in two business meetings and so
how do you do that you become memorable
I take advantage of like my extroverted
personality and like the charisma that I
was gifted but I think you need to back
up that sizzle right and I take a lot of
pride in my ability to be a practitioner
in my ability to do I've gotten better
and better and better at like keeping my
word that's always you know tough
because you know I would have all these
ambitions and I'm always on the offense
and that is something I've gotten
you know so I guess you know just just a
good human being who cared about who
cared about more things than just
himself question of the day what do I
want to know today um I'm an interesting
zone tonight like very focused usually
when the lights come on I can get out of
it and go into the zone but I mean I'm
in hardcore focus mode talk to me about
what you are focusing on the most in
your life right now thanks for watching
episode 73 getting close to a hundred
guys you know didn't we mail in fifty I
was talking a big game and then we
didn't do anything crazy right is that
what happened we just kind of like we
talked to big game timing windows right
timing windows that was fun
we need that you know what that's
another side question what do you want
from me
on episode 100 because it's gonna sneak
up it's close the NFL draft talk that
we've been having is interesting you
know but I don't think it's gonna work
right like I'd have to really like
alright I'm traveling a March is gonna
be a crap month we should have said that
now they just heard it you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them in
April